Speaker 1: . The Trump DeSantis feud has exploded
as Donald Trump spent the entire weekend posting
two truth social censure attacks on Ron DeSantis,
including going full rhino Trump giving Ron
DeSantis the full rhino treatment.
Speaker 2: Remember that Rhino means.
Speaker 1: Republican in name only.
It's a pejorative attached to Republicans
that someone feels aren't.
Speaker 2: Really.
Speaker 1: Republican.
So let's take a look at Trump's posts.
He is not holding back despite claiming he
doesn't even think about Ron DeSantis.
He spent the entire weekend posting about
him.
Trump first posting quote in writer Salena
Zito's fake news puff piece about DeSantis,
which supposedly appeared.
Speaker 2: In the dying New York Post.
Speaker 1: Which is way down in readership,
just like.
Speaker 2: Fox News is way down in ratings.
Speaker 1: Why doesn't she mention that he
wants to cut Social Security and Medicare?
Loves losers like Jeb Bush, Paul Ryan, and
Karl Rove.
And it getting clobbered in the polls by me.
DeSantis is a RINO who is trying to hide his
past.
I don't read the New York Post anymore.
It has become fake news, just like Fox and
the Wall Street Journal.
Anyone who doesn't suck up to Trump and pray
at the altar.
Speaker 2: Of the great failed.
Speaker 1: Former president is now a.
Speaker 2: RINO and is fake news and is bad.
Speaker 1: But understand that this is a dramatic
escalation.
Trump last week said, I don't.
Speaker 2: Even think about Ron DeSantis.
Speaker 1: And then he spent the.
Speaker 2: Entire weekend.
Speaker 1: Trotting about Ron DeSantis.
Trump Continuing.
Trump And by the way, isn't Trump really the
rhino?
And what I mean by that is Trump never represented
Republican values.
Trump wasn't even really a Republican that
we knew of for the vast majority of his life
until he started getting traction by criticizing
Barack Obama.
Now, if there's any real rhino, it's actually
Trump.
But let's put that aside for a second.
Trump continuing to post quote, Ron, too sanctimonious,
wants to cut your Social Security and Medicare,
closed up Florida and its beaches.
Loves rhinos, Paul Ryan, Jeb Bush and Karl
Rove disasters.
All is backed by globalists Club for No growth
link and pervert project and uninspired coke.
And it only gets worse from there.
He is a rhino in disguise whose poll numbers
are dropping like a rock.
Good luck, Ron.
You know, for a guy who says I don't think
about Ron DeSantis, he will not stop posting
about Ron DeSantis and seems completely consumed
by Ron DeSantis.
And that's how, you know, Trump is lying when
he says, I don't ever think about this thing.
And anybody who says I.
Speaker 2: Do is wrong and bad and evil and
lying.
Speaker 1: It's a signal that that's exactly
what.
Speaker 2: He's spending his time thinking
about.
And it's clear that he is.
Speaker 1: And then another one this.
Speaker 2: Morning.
Speaker 1: Trump just out of control.
Essential Quote Support for DeSantis Cools
in Latest GOP Poll.
Washington Times.
Of course it cools.
He wants to cut Social Security and Medicare
loves throw them off the cliff.
Paul Ryan, who is destroying Fox News and
the Wall Street Journal piglet Karl Rove and
quote Jeb also run to sanctimonious is for
Globalist Club for No Growth and Open borders.
Charles Koch.
We want America first, not America last.
That's the ranting of a madman.
Speaker 2: There's no denying it.
There's no way around it.
Speaker 1: But I said, I don't know if all
of.
Speaker 2: These guys and gals really have
what it takes.
Speaker 1: To face Trump in a national campaign
in which Trump ignores all rules of decorum,
the very same ignoring of all the rules of
decorum.
Speaker 2: That made the U.S..
Speaker 1: A joke internationally when Donald
Trump was president are the rules of decorum
that generate media attention and that get
those folks who aren't that close followers
of politics, but they like a good fight and
an interesting, combative personality.
It brings them out of the woodwork.
And that's why Trump won in 2016.
It was missing from 2020.
That part of why Trump lost 2020.
Aside from failing on COVID is that he didn't
have the environment that he had in 2016 to
do this sort of stuff.
This really is Trump in his element.
That's the crazy thing.
And so I know not everybody in the audience
agrees with me on this.
I think unless someone can match Trump on
this sort of stuff, he has a very good shot.
Speaker 2: At running away with the 2024 nomination.
Speaker 1: Let me know what you think.
Leave a comment.
Let me know what you think and look forward
to hearing
from you.